[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
hello
i'm professor brian keating chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at
the university of california san diego
and the co-director of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination and
today's topic continues this grand
tradition of trying to understand how
did we get here not only us but also all
these little twinkling lights in the
background behind me in the hubble ultra
deep field
each image there each pixel each speck
of light
is a galaxy not a star and each galaxy
there is comprised of maybe perhaps 100
billion to 500 billion stars perhaps
they have planets perhaps they have
cosmologists and perhaps they have
curious characters like you and me
because my motto is abc always be
curious and this is part of my outreach
attempt to give
information to you the tax paying public
and the communication of the most
fascinating topics in all of physics and
cosmology and there's really nothing
bigger than the question of how did the
universe begin
and in so doing we will take a journey
back to perhaps the origin of time
itself in the theory known as cosmic
inflation now this is controversial and
this came about as a response to an
earlier theory which itself was first
thought to be outlandish and that was
the big bang model the big bang model
was was really first encountered as a
consequence of einstein's theory of
general relativity
and that theory of relativity had within
it
the seeds of an expanding universe and
that expanding universe if run backwards
would then predict that things in the
universe such as galaxies and maybe even
other objects would be compressed
perhaps into what was called a primeval
atom by george lemaitre famous belgian
catholic priest inflation the theory
arose as we discussed in a previous
video as a response to the known flaws
or gaps or holes in the big bang model
that i call cracks in the cosmic egg and
those are going to be very briefly
indicated and glossed over here and i
refer you to this video up here which
where we talk about the problems in the
big bang that ushered in the concept of
inflation
now those three main pillars that
cosmologists often talk about or flaws
in the big bang model are also shown
behind me in this video but we're not
going to talk about them again i refer
you to the previous video the primary
one that first attracted some a large
measure of attention is the so-called
flatness problem why do all triangles in
the universe no matter how big or small
sum to an interior angle of 180 degrees
no matter how big you make a triangle
out of stars out of galaxies out of even
fluctuations in the cosmic microwave
background this was a puzzle and the
puzzle gets even more pronounced and
more difficult and more vexing the
earlier in time you go back
so starting from today we know the
universe is flat to a precision of about
one half of one percent meaning that
there is no discernible curvature
positive or negative positive being a
sphere negative being a saddle or
pringle and the problem gets worse if
you go earlier in time in fact you get
exponentially worse you can get as bad
as you want when you go back to the
so-called radiation-dominated epoch of
the early universe so when the first
elements were formed they were formed
during a period of time in which the
dominant contributor to the universe's
energy budget was in the form of heat
well that would later become the cosmic
microwave background radiation but for
that period of time was really just
gamma rays and and uh and very high
energy ultraviolet rays and they were
bombarding and dissociating and even
causing atoms themselves and nuclei of
atoms to dissociate if you go earlier
back in time so this is a great problem
why is the universe so flat and it must
have been born since the universe has to
only diverge very very slowly with time
as time increases its curvature
increases ever so slowly then that means
that in the early universe it must have
been radically more flat if you could
imagine it flatter than florida as i
have to say so when you look back into
the early universe it makes things worse
and so that was a problem in the big
bang because the big bang proports to
explain the universe at its earliest
moment maybe even time equals zero we'll
explore the notion of time in a later
video
so that was one of the gaps in the uh in
the big bang model that led to the
notion of the solution being needed
crying out for an explanation not by
fiat not by god because cosmologists
aren't find that notion antithetical to
the practice of science but instead to
some kind of purported earlier more
primal mechanism that will turn out to
be inflation spoiler alert
now the horizon problem is the
observation that no matter which two
directions you look in the cosmos even
if you look 180 degrees apart looking in
front of myself looking all the way to
the back the temperature of the cmb is
equal to a part in about 10 to the minus
four so one part and ten thousand
fluctuation will be the amount of fine
tuning of the universe's temperature and
this is thought to be impossible in any
other uh cosmological scenario where you
just propagate the big bang model
forward from the earliest epoch in which
we understand how the universe of
physical functions were taking place
namely the formation of the first light
nuclei in their isotopes
but instead if you go back earlier in
time the coincidence that's required has
to be absurd we have to have a fine
tuning and a degree of matching
at the parts per 100 000 or even more if
you go back to the earliest moments in
the universe that is known as the
horizon problem the uniformity nearly so
of the cosmic microwave background's
temperature historically the first
problem that alan guth
was led to uh think about a notion of
astroparticle cosmology involved what's
known as the monopole problem which is
that if you extrapolate back in time you
go up in temperature and if you go back
to when the cmb was formed it was formed
at a temperature characteristic
temperature of the entire universe the
other thermometer it would be about 3
000 kelvin and therefore it's cooled off
by a thousand times the universe has
expanded the scale factor by a thousand
times in those remaining 14 billion
years nearly but before that you go back
in time and the temperature rises again
exponentially and it goes as a very
steep power of the size of the universe
in fact if you try to make it zero the
universe would have infinite temperature
and those are problems in so-called
singularity theorems that we're going to
explore in particular the board
gouthalenkin theorem which i want to get
into in a future video
but before we get there we have to
understand why cosmologists like to talk
about inflation so much and we've gone a
deep dive into some of the problems with
inflation but it's important to get a
good foundation as to what inflation
actually predicts what it explains and
what it fails to explain and what other
gaps it has and always remember in
science the job of the science is not to
explain everything perfectly with no
uncertainty it's to characterize the
uncertainty that we have about the
quantities we claim to know about so no
scientist should ever say we know
something with absolute scientific
certainty there always has to be some
uncertainty in fact it's not known that
the universe is completely flat because
we have this half percent uncertainty in
its curvature and that's astounding
because when i was a graduate student we
thought the universe was essentially an
open universe which meant that it had
about 30 percent not a half a percent it
was off by factors of of 60 or or maybe
70 percent from what we know it to be
today so factors of hundreds maybe even
thousands of improvement just in 25 or
30 years since i was a wee lad and
student at brown university
now looking back in time we look back in
temperature temperature goes up gets
higher particle physicists think that we
will unify the fundamental forces of
nature that are at least the three most
powerful forces for short-range forces
the grand unified theory so to speak
contains within it that hopes to unify
the strong interaction of nuclear
physics the weak nuclear force along
with electromagnetism and
electromagnetism in the weak theory have
been unified as we talked about earlier
in those processes of transitioning from
one phase of the universe when it was
dominated by perhaps two forces gravity
and a grand unified theory or maybe even
earlier going back to a theory of
everything and there's only one force
later on shattering if you will into
four different uh manifestations gravity
in the two nuclear forces plus
electromagnetism
when
the universe underwent a so-called phase
transition it is thought that there
could be leftover relics sometimes
called topological defects one of which
being magnetic monopoles
so as i explained earlier magnetic
fields magnetic objects
if you look at a magnet itself it always
has a north pole and a south pole even
when you crack it apart and you get a
north and south and a north and the
south you never get an isolated north
pole with no south pole and a south pole
to north pole
so the expectation was if the universe
had a grand unified epoch it would have
transitioned through a phase transition
that would have then led it to acquire
within it these topological defects of
which one would be a magnetic monopole
and yet we've never observed a magnetic
monopole and there should be trillions
and trillions and trillions of them as
we talked about and actually estimated
in previous videos
and and so it's actually quite
astounding that we don't see a lot of
these and in fact that we even exist
because these monopoles would be quite
massive far more massive than the amount
of ordinary matter in the universe and
that would cause the universe to
collapse long ago so our existence means
that we might owe ourselves to the
absence of magnetic monopoles and yet in
our best theory of cosmoparticle physics
they should be abundant the universe
should be rotten with magnetic monopoles
we believe that they're not because some
process has diluted them so much that we
don't see them today and that'll
actually be a culmination of what we
talk about today inflation is a proposed
solution
to all three of these problems and
perhaps more
what inflation does is add to the early
universe's big bang and even bigger bang
at an even earlier epoch namely not at
the beginning of time but perhaps as
early as 10 to the minus 36 seconds
after the origin of our observable
universe whatever that means we'll have
to get into in a separate topic
the universe underwent a hyper active
expansion and in fact that expansion
wasn't constant like stepping on the gas
pedal with constant pressure it was
actually flooring the gas pedal and
accelerating increasing our velocity or
the universe's velocity increasing the
scale factor of space time
which is described in a dynamical
equation shown at the top called the
acceleration equation
the acceleration equation shows that for
any substance that has what is called a
negative equation of state in other
words most materials like a gas and a
piston when you compress it the piston
wants to repel and go back out and be
pushed out by the compression of
ordinary matter inside of the cylinder
now with the cylinder reform or were
containing this material
that had a bizarre property that the
more you pressed it the more it sucked
in the piston inside the cylinder that
would be said to have a negative
equation of state
and we don't know an encounter in
ordinary physics and ordinary experience
something with negative energy but it is
believed that the large-scale
acceleration of the universe that we
observe in distant galaxies today
owes itself to a type of material and
property of space called dark energy
that has a negative equation of state
parameter this parameter w
is believed to be sufficiently negative
to cause late time i.e at 14 billion
years after the big bang
expansion at an accelerated rate but it
actually doesn't need to be as big as it
is uh to cause this property of space to
expand so rapidly now during this early
period
the equation of state had this form and
as the universe evolves the expansion of
the scale factor this quantity a this is
the master governing parameter of the
universe it's a characteristic scale
size of our universe at any given moment
and it depends on the composition of the
universe we can't actually observe the
scale factor a itself we can only
observe ratios of it and derivatives of
it during inflation
the first derivative of the scale factor
namely how fast is the universe's size
scale increasing or decreasing it was
getting bigger and it was getting bigger
at a rate shown on the left to the just
to the left of the first right pointing
arrow
and that shows that as long as it had a
value of that second derivative as long
as that value is greater than zero the
universe will expand at an accelerating
rate
later when we plug in that equation and
solve that equation
for the governing equation of cosmology
called the friedman equations which
themselves come from the einstein's
theory of general relativity in an
expanding space time the amount of
expansion i.e the hubble constant is
very simple to calculate the hubble
constant is the evaluation of the hubble
parameter which is just the time
derivative of the scale factor at any
given moment
from the friedman equation we get that
the expansion of the scale factor a of t
will grow exponentially at a rate
governed by this hubble parameter h i
during inflation
now if this is constant during inflation
if h is constant the universe will
expand at a rate of e to the lambda
over 3 to the square root power so we
can solve those equations those aren't
actually very difficult to to solve and
we can evaluate three different epochs
we can evaluate an epoch before
inflation took place i told you that
inflation took place at a time we call a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second a second after
what well that we have to determine that
could be a previous universe's collapse
it could be the origin of time itself
that is yet unknown and very interesting
to consider and we will do so at length
on this channel but suppose there was
this exponential period that then began
at this trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second before that the
universe was just growing due to the
fact that it contained a lot of heat
so somehow the universe was created or
born or nucleated in an initial state
before inflation in this paradigm that
had copious amounts of radiation because
of its or small size and high density
nothing material could really exist
without getting completely annihilated
and converted via e equals mc squared
into pure energy we talk about energy we
really mean photonic energy therefore
the early universe the predecessor
universe to inflation that epoch was
radiation dominated we know very well
how the universe grows during radiation
domination
and that will also take place after
inflation ends at this time we mark t
final
and as long as the inner the universe
grows
uh during this period of time it will
have to grow
exponentially fast at an accelerating
rate
and that accelerating rate is governed
by the value of lambda where lambda here
means the inflaton energy
and so when you design a model of
inflation you sometimes will work
backwards from the observables the
universe is flat it has no monopoles it
has the horizon problem and we want to
extrapolate a solution to it we'll say
oh how much expansion did the universe
have to have
that will set limits on how much the
inflationary parameters changed or were
their values at the early universe's
first epoch it's a simple matter to
calculate what the are to determine and
to define what's called the number of e
foldings that's the number of times the
universe not doubled in size but
increased by 2.78 that number to the
power n is typically what we call the
number of e foldings and you can relate
that it's almost the square root of the
number of uh of 10x
multiples of the universe so how much
does the universe grow in size as
ordinary exponential notation so as i
say at the bottom if the universe was in
this inflationary epoch for long enough
where long enough only has to be a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second or so we'll talk
about that then the universe can grow by
a huge amount
so there can be an incredible growth in
the scale factor of the universe meaning
that things that have the size scale of
a proton can grow if this number is big
enough to arbitrary sizes they can get
as large as a meter so they can go grow
by tens of orders of magnitude from the
early universe's inflationary epoch
and
this is not proving that inflation took
place by any means it's just saying if
the universe had a period of early
acceleration
what would the consequences be and how
much does that acceleration have to do
to the size of the universe how much
accelera how long are you holding down
the gas pedal for so we typically depict
the time in which the unification of the
strong weak and electromagnetic forces
could take place
that equates to an energy we can equate
that energy the energy of grand
unification from two or three slides ago
we can convert that to a time that's
where we get this 10 to the minus 36
seconds or 10
a trillionth of a trillion for the
trillionth of a second so we're really
going backwards so you don't even have
to ask what happened after what you know
what was t equals 0 on this exponential
notation where inflation begins at 10 to
the minus 36 seconds you can start from
today and go all the way backwards to 14
billion years minus 3 minutes minus 10
to the minus 36 seconds something like
that to produce the exponential
expansion at that time at 10 to the
minus 36 seconds requires that lambda be
almost 100 over 100 orders of magnitude
greater than we observe the dark energy
to be today in other words today we have
we are witnessing an acceleration of out
of a the scale factor is getting bigger
the hubble constant is increasing with
time
and therefore we are undergoing a period
of expansion via this dark energy type
of phenomena of which we don't really
understand that much and we will talk a
lot about that
and we will ask the question though in
this context how big does the universe
is dark energy how big would it have to
be back in the early time to account for
the inflation that we believe is
necessary to explain these lacunae in
the big bang
and that's a huge huge differential it's
107 orders of magnitude difference so
the curvature diverges and grows
exponentially or geometrically bigger as
you go back in time during this early
epoch during the radiation dominated
phase in fact it grows as the speed of
light squared which has dimensions of
velocity over something that has
dimensions of velocity
uh per
per unit distance per unit time
and that's the hubble parameter h of t
and also this characteristic scale are
not where r naught is the radius of
curvature of a curved universe now we
only know the absolute value of this
term we can only calculate this from our
friedman equations
but if you go back and you go back early
in time you find that the universe is
incredibly flat and it gets flatter and
flatter the earlier you go back in time
and in fact you need a certain number of
e foldings so that the deviation from
one minus omega which governs how curved
the universe is becomes as close as you
want to zero in other words we can make
the universe
born with a decimal place in its
curvature and an infinite number of
zeros if we want and then finally a one
at the very end you can never make it
perfectly perfectly flat by
extrapolating from what today's values
are if it diverges but you can get
arbitrarily close to zero curvature
which means that you solve today's
curvature problem
by virtue of the fact that in the
initial moments of cosmic history
the curvature of the universe was so
flat
so
iron taught
that the universe would have had so
little curvature then that no matter how
much it grew you're basically
multiplying zero by a large number and
the elapsed amount of time that the
universe has had to grow you're
multiplying a decently large number but
you're multiplying basically zero and
you can get it as close to zero as you
want such that by today you can get at
most a half a percent deviation from
perfect flatness and that is the only
amount that is tolerable so
the question is how many e foldings do
you need to get this flatness problem
out of our hair and that actually turns
out to be a number that's not actually
that big it's 60 times the universe has
to not double in size but increase by a
power of e to some power e to the 60th
power
which is something like 10 to the 30th
power so it's a big number it's a lot of
foldings
but you're going from the size scale of
a proton to something macroscopic human
scale meter scale and you're doing that
though in an incredibly short period of
time 10 to the minus 36 seconds
and in so doing you could make the
universe completely flat back then
such that by now even with a tiny bit of
amplification of almost zero you still
have effectively zero curvature
that's how inflation would solve the
flatness problem and it only needs to
increase by this much to a match
observed data from the cosmic microwave
background as we've discussed in the
previous video the next problem is the
horizon problem we talked about that as
a problem that really is indicative of
the fact that the universe has a certain
size scale over which it can communicate
and that's effectively the maximum
distance that information can travel is
essentially the age of the universe at
any given moment
times the speed of light it can do so in
both directions forward and backwards
left and right up and down
and so the question of why is the
universe so connected together today 13
billion years
later more than almost 14 billion years
later
can be solved by inflation by looking at
how small the universe was
at that time the universe that would
grow into our observable universe how
close was it to being completely uniform
or very close to uniform at the early
epoch known as inflation so to do that
we talked about solving the horizon
problem the horizon problem is a
as a description of how much the
universe can vary from uh from point to
point and how big the universe can grow
within the bounds of the period of time
known as inflation so from the previous
slide to in order to understand how much
the universe has increased from the time
of 10 to the minus 36 seconds
how big did the universe increase by it
went from a size of 10 to the minus 28
meters as i said much much smaller than
the size of a proton
and it expanded by 60 e foldings maybe
for sake of making a convenient argument
we expanded from that size scale up by e
to the 60th or e to the 65 for this
comparison so it went from the size of a
sub atomic particle smaller than say the
radius classical radius of the electron
and increased to the size of a whale so
how does this solve the horizon problem
after inflation as we said before
inflation and after inflation the
universe is so called radiation
dominated its expansion rate it's
acceleration everything depends only on
the amount of heat that's in the
universe not any matter it's way too
early for matter like even quarks
and so forth to form so the only
substance that's there are photons
photons are particles of light and heat
so the universe grows by this certain
amount after inflation it also grows at
the same rate before inflation and so
this diagram is showing how big is the
horizon over what distance could
information be
allowed to propagate and tell different
regions of the universe to set your
thermostat to my value of the thermostat
so that we come to equilibrium when 13
billion years plus elapse later on we
can show that the fluctuations in the
amount of heat energy in this early
universe were as uniform as required to
solve the horizon problem and you go
through the calculation
and you find that at the time the
universe produced the cosmic background
radiation this pattern from the wmap
experiment that the universe has
increased from the scale factor of 10 to
the minus 27 and it's grown to a size of
10 to the minus 4 10 minus 3 by the time
the cmb was produced that we observed
later so we're really measuring how bad
the horizon problem was when the
universe produced the cosmic microwave
background anisotropy so we find that if
the universe underwent this rapid period
of acceleration during this very brief
epoch it only lasts as shown here for a
very small fraction 10 minus 35 of a
second 10 minus 36 of a second
very very brief amount of time and yet
in so doing it can then terminate the
inflationary epoch and end and then the
universe can evolve just the way we
observed it evolving during the
formation of the elements and then after
in matter domination and now in lambda
domination and it can do so such that by
today's time the universe has had enough
time for all the matter that was there
to come to the same temperature and the
universe to exhibit the large-scale lack
of variation that we observe this weird
coincidence that completely opposite
regions of the cosmic background
radiation have the exact same
temperature to apart and 10 to the
fourth and we can do that incredibly
accurately and in this way this brief
amount of time causes is enough to cause
the universe to um to inflate enough to
solve so far to solve this horizon
problem
and we will see how it then impacts on
the flatness and on the observation of
the universe's lack of magnetic
monopoles
so let's take a step back
imagine a region of the universe today
we can see
that is effectively encapsulated by our
cosmic microwave background the spheres
or the surrounding
photon shell that comes to us in all
directions so
consider the distance to the cosmic
microwave background's last scattering
surface
that is approximately 40 billion or so
light years away from us even though the
universe is only
14 billion years old it is far larger
than 14 billion light years away from us
because universe has expanded so much
since that period of time when the cmb
was produced and the universe may have
undergone this early period earlier
primal period of expansion called
inflation
so what it the picture that inflation
develops
is that all the mass and all the energy
all of what would later become the
galaxies stars and so forth that are
contained in the hubble deep field image
that i showed at the very beginning
those arose from the same patch of the
primordial universe just after inflation
and so what we see today
is actually just a different fragment or
an expanded version of a very very
extremely uniform region of space-time
at an extremely early period of time
there's not enough time if you just
merely extrapolate in the no inflation
curve you can't get to the degree of
uniformity that we see in the cosmic ray
background there's a gap on the far
right between the solid line and the
dashed line without inflation and note
again that inflation is not needed at a
period earlier than about 10 to the
minus 36 seconds so for that reason
people do talk about inflation
incorrectly in my opinion they talk
about it as the origin of time they talk
about it as the origin of the universe
it's really not that
in fact from the perspective of no
inflation versus inflation they both
have a common history
before at periods earlier than 10 to the
minus 36 seconds going back as far back
as you like perhaps to the planck time
of 10 to the minus 42 seconds so that
again re-emphasizes the point i've made
many times in this channel inflation is
not to be thought of as a theory of the
genesis of the universe but of the
evolution of the universe after some
period of time if it indeed is the
correct paradigm and so finally
inflation explains these three problems
it explains the flatness of the universe
solves the problem of the isotropy of
the kazakh microwave background explains
why the universe is so flat because it
was born exquisitely flat and it solves
the uniformity of the cosmic microwave
background as well as explaining that
any region of the universe of any size
would have expanded away any magnetic
monopoles that were there to far beyond
the cosmic horizon so we might expect
only one monopole per universe or per
universal sized object we'll talk about
that more
later and so we would never expect to
encounter on earth or in the solar
system the magnetic monopole floating
around in our observable universe the
odds of that are literally
astronomically forbidden
so inflation does all these things it
explains what the universe looks like on
its largest scales we'll see later where
does structure come from inflation is a
very good theory of cosmic structure
formation provided you accept that
inflation actually occurred because what
inflation will allow us to do is explain
not only the large scale flatness of the
universe but also the small scale
non-flatness and crinkliness of the
universe namely how did the universe
seed the primordial objects of early
wells of dark matter that would then
create ordinary matter that would then
ignite to form the first stars galaxies
etc so inflation has a proposal for that
and for that i will refer you to our
next video for now signing off brian
keating chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics and co-director of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination for the into the impossible
podcast if you enjoyed this video you
definitely want to check out this
playlist with
my cosmology friends talking about the
origin and evolution of the universe
and if you're interested in a deep dive
in the multiverse wormholes and other
exotic phenomena click here and hear my
conversation with juan maldasena of the
institute for advanced study enjoy and
don't forget to subscribe for more
amazing content
[Music]
you